alright guys I'm super excited wills
here you guys have built probably one of
those popular applications on Lightning
Network and have a whole bunch of cool
backstories and kind of views on the
world so thanks so much for coming in
and talking about all this pomp it's
good to be here
happy to talk about full lightning I
think gonna have a good cut yeah for
sure
the other thing before we get started
will told me that he got engaged last
year and so we were swapping notes on on
the wedding planning which is now become
a thing in my life so we'll see how this
goes it's important to share what you
learned coming after you it's it's a you
know it's an adventure so happy to share
most adventures in life I look forward
to the describing wedding planning is an
adventure I don't know about we'll see
it's one that you're gonna try to hide
from but you got to take it for head-on
yeah alright let's talk about your
background kind of before you got into
crypto Bitcoin what what were you doing
I'm gonna pre all that so I'm uh based
out of California I've spent a lot of
time down in Silicon Valley my my main
focus has been building companies in
payments retail consumer space started a
company you know building payment
processing kind of subscription stuff
and then moved quickly into building out
systems for you know Google store to
launch that and so had a really wide
variety of building companies myself
being embedded in you know some of the
large you know Silicon Valley stuff down
there that I've got a got to learn quite
a bit from but you know really coming to
Bitcoin was was one of the best
decisions I could have made for sure you
remember the first time you ever heard
about it oh yeah I was living down in
Argentina it was down there for about a
year and there was a family party at the
family that I was staying and and one of
the cousins was a security engineer down
there and this was maybe 2011 or so and
he was telling me about this thing
called Bitcoin and
he was he was extremely bullish on it
very early on and that was pretty much
the first time I heard about it now he
I've since kept in contact with this guy
you know Argentina's gone through a
couple defaults since then and he not
only has weathered that storm but come
out pretty well and so like the idea
Bitcoin safe hey is an asset in
turbulent economies was just a use case
that just hit me right over the head
yeah we had Camilla Russo who's writing
a book on a theorem she was a reporter
at Bloomberg kind of 2011-2012 timeframe
and she was one of the first people to
talk about Bitcoin at Bloomberg because
she was covering the Argentine markets
they have a bunch of traders and
everything they were talking about it
what was it like living in Argentina
let's see oh my god it's a it's a crazy
City it is one of those places that is a
little bastion of Europe in the middle
of Latin America I had no idea what was
gonna be there and so of course I land
in a house full of tango dancers and so
when you get into a situation like that
you're gonna see the heart of of
Argentina and so I had a pretty an
incredible experience I hope to go back
soon
yeah that's awesome and then to living
Argentina here about Bitcoin don't do
anything at the time no this is just
starting to follow it you know kind of
from a curiosity standpoint I came back
and you know I had some other
experiences you know I'm I'm from Sonoma
Valley where we had a big migrant worker
population and I was active in building
out service local services for them
housing legal aid and so we would bring
people in to talk about you know and
provide new services for these migrant
workers that are coming in that are you
know typically not paid attention to and
we had one guy come in and present on
Bitcoin as a remittance tool which again
was one of those things okay borderless
payments unstoppable you know on the
censorship resistant use case and it was
another one of those who's like okay
it's coming up again this is this is
rearing its head and so it took about
three or four major moments of
experiencing it before I started to
not only it basically put started to put
skin in the game start to follow it not
only from a kind of intellectual
standpoint but start to follow the
development and take a deeper look for
sure and then so as you're going through
that you're obviously paying attention
to building payment technology etc at
what point do you decide like hey maybe
actually I want to go build in the space
so the about two years ago is when I
actually Dolan and was actually starting
to build before then I had been building
peer-to-peer marketplaces how can you
take two strangers bring them together
and exchange a car exchange a home so
essentially how do you have a big bag of
cash and a very expensive asset and
bring two people who don't know you know
each other together and somehow come out
with a happy transaction on the other
side and of course there's issues of
trust safety and when you look at just
even of the payment tools that we have
at our disposal most of them aren't
necessarily built for that they're
they're built for an intermediary to be
there and so there were a you know you'd
I would constantly be working in
payments and retail start to see the
bounds of where you know our existing
infrastructure kind of doesn't support
these use cases and kind of starts to
fail I mean I think it works in a lot of
cases but in some things global
transactions trust based peer-to-peer
payments are some of the areas where it
was immediately clear that Bitcoin or
technologies like it could present new
solutions that would open up new
opportunities new industries and so I
started to really focus on that got it
and then maybe talk through a little bit
kind of the idea for fold and how you
guys got started and what that original
vision was like yeah I mean so you know
fold really started off as Bitcoin is
growing there are more and more people
with it and you know when they have this
the idea is to show its use cases in the
real world you know besides just you
know huddling and which is essentially a
private action that takes place kind of
on an individual level
there was you know an idea of okay what
other use case is this you know and so
payments was a thing that people talked
a lot about you know gotta buy that
coffee and so fold was originally built
to enable someone to spend Bitcoin and
get their coffee and so you know the the
success of that originally was that it
provided a new social a moment for
bitcoiners to show people around them in
a real environment hey look I'm using
this in in the real world it's a real
thing it's tangible and for a lot of
people trying to wrap their heads around
a new asset a new type of money a
transact able currency is something
that's important to them even though you
know what we've come to learn is that
the narrative has gone much farther with
what Bitcoin can do and be and so you
know besides the ability to show hey
friends I just you know bought my
Starbucks we quickly learned that you
know the as bitcoins stood was just not
gonna be a transacting layer on
Unchained ten-minute confirmation times
means that you're gonna piss a lot of
people off in the Starbucks lines you
know high fees depending on congestion
five-dollar fees and a five-dollar
coffee it just became obvious that that
everyday transactions and small payments
we're just not going to happen on chain
and so we knew that we had to kind of
evolve with the narrative a Bitcoin move
with that and that layer to is we're
really where this use case was going to
grow if it was going to grow anywhere
and so I guess the key piece to all of
this was like in the early days of
Bitcoin like how did people actually you
know drive adoption it was literally hey
pull out your phone or get your computer
let me get you a wallet and I'll give
you some Bitcoin yeah right it was this
kind of virality of money if you will
was how a lot of early bitcoiners came
into the ecosystem so they heard from
somebody then that person said let me
give you some and so it's a form of skin
in the game breaks now I have this asset
that I own that has monetary value to it
people pay attention and then you're
hoping that they then meet somebody else
tell them about it and then they go
ahead and they give them some Bitcoin
and it kind of you know goes on and on
and on and spreads to eventually
millions of people
I mean what we what we've seen is you
know that that moment of that giving
moment had both skin in the game that
you actually got people holding the
asset which is number one what we've
come to learn is one of the most
important hurdles to get over just give
people some Bitcoin give them some
ability to watch the price action watch
number go up watch it go down and start
to harden them in that way and just
build their curiosity about that the
other part is early days Bitcoin it was
it was a friend showing another friend
so there was this other element of a
this viral network of trusted you know
friends family that we're just kind of
spreading this gospel spreading this
word and so it had this viral element
but also this kind of built-in trust
with having someone you knew refer it to
you and it was kind of a secret that was
being told to you and so it had this you
know at that point there's limits to how
much that style of virality can grow and
so what we've done it fold and what I've
been trying to focus on is how do we
expand these ways of mimicking this
virality and you know ultimately is what
we've seen over the past years is people
tapping into existing industries
existing mechanisms of essentially money
transfer and start to flow that into
into Bitcoin and so for us rewards is a
big thing you know if if all the rewards
in the US were instead of being
distributed in airline miles and points
given as Bitcoin 16 million Bitcoin
would have been distributed to people
around the in the United States alone so
we start to see how we can take these
existing behaviors that people do every
day and kind of rework them in a way
that doesn't make people change their
behaviors but gives new flows a Bitcoin
to distribute it to more people in
shorter amounts of time yeah and really
the way that I think about kind of the
adoption of a lot of this stuff is when
people come in through price speculation
right so prices going up or going down
and people are coming in because they
look at as a tradable asset that's a
very different track or path to follow
and you come at it from a different
perspective than if I earned the Bitcoin
or
somebody gave it to me and I under with
the understanding that it's money and
I'm to spend this at some other point
right and so I think a lot about like if
you bifurcated the bitcoin adopters
today let's call it seventy million
people right 1% of the world's
population give or take what percentage
is the speculators right and here is hey
this is a trading asset versus the
people who are here to use it as a
currency and and purchasing mechanism I
think we would all agree like there's a
lot of speculators right yeah and the
work you guys are doing it almost feels
like when you're trying to bring new
people into to have them come in as that
hey this is money this is payment
technology etc but to is you actually
can pull some of those speculators over
and kind of have them cross over into
you can use this as money as well so you
kind of attack it from both sides
there's there's no doubt that right now
primary use case the most people using
and are using it for speculative
purposes and the odd lers I mean
essentially you know the way the way I
think about it is that you know when
once the first Genesis block was mined
the rudimentary technology to support
modeling and in the accumulation use
case of Bitcoin was the technology was
pretty much there send/receive and just
wait it out and so for us it's really
about looking at the new use cases to
expand what we understand Bitcoin to be
and for the most part the idea of
earning and spending the infrastructure
just has not been there the it has not
been possible to deliver a user
experience that is at the expectation of
mainstream consumers and so for us it's
really about pushing the at the protocol
layer at the application layer to start
to test out that experiment of Bitcoin
as a meet of exchange but also to make
it easier to earn you know with with
fold it's not just about spending
Bitcoin it's about it's about earning it
when you're using your credit card when
you're using you know your USD your Fiat
and the idea is that we get to start you
know get that curiosity the people that
aren't there to speculate that honestly
get turned off by exchange environments
where there's you know red numbers
flaring green it's stress
full it's confusing it's expensive at
times and the utility is not necessarily
immediately available to them and so for
us it's it's about building the
infrastructure to help people learn
about this asset slowly start to
accumulate Bitcoin they don't have to
spend it they don't have to have it and
they start to start to see this you know
and and the average user is about five
hundred Satoshi's or five hundred
thousand satoshis a month right now and
so what we see is people start to learn
about it people and then we get support
tickets coming and saying hey do I spend
this Bitcoin or am I supposed to hold it
you know what do I do with this and so
what we've essentially opened up is just
an education machine for how to bring in
people who haven't had experience with
the asset don't necessarily know what it
is but are there to learn about it and
so with fold what we're trying to do is
create all these moments of Education
what is a wallet what's the best wallet
for you how do you think about spending
it you know we are we are totally here
for the use case of accumulation
huddling and you know everyone on the
fold team fits that fits that bill but
we also know that there are very real
use cases for around the world of
spending it using it in their daily
lives and we also are enabling that as
well and we're doing that through
incentives not just telling you you
should do it for sure so let's talk
about what's the functionality available
to me as a user of fold today
so fold available App Store Android
Store download all mobile all mobile ok
we started off on the web but we're
primarily focused on mobile so you
download the app sync credit card debit
card and then from there we have right
now currently 30 different merchants
available Amazon Starbucks uber and you
go about spending like you do you you
know every day you're ordering coffee
you're ordering a car you're you're
making your Amazon shipments and instead
you do that with fold and what you do is
you buy essentially prepaid credit into
these stores so you know go into Amazon
buy $100 of credit which is
automatically loaded into your Amazon
account and from there you're gonna earn
two to four percent back and Satoshi's
instantly now on your next purchase you
can decide hey I'm going to increase my
spending power and use that Bitcoin to
supplement my neck
purchase or you can you can you know
save it accumulate it and the idea is
that we both accept credit cards but we
also allow you to spend Bitcoin via
lightning and so one of the points of
education that we have is that if you're
spending with Bitcoin you're gonna get
three to four percent higher more cash
back per transaction so the idea is
we're you know we you can kind of
imagine what's happened with cash app
you look at Cash app and it is the
number one financial app in the App
Store and in front of all of these
mainstream consumers who may have never
heard about Bitcoin there's an entire
tab about Bitcoin teaching them about it
exposing them to that and so the idea is
that we're not beating over the head
about what to use Bitcoin or what you
know how you should be using them but or
giving you an on-ramp to start to start
to learn more about it and to take the
next steps of actually starting to
actually use it and get onboard it into
wallets into the infrastructure because
there are behavioral changes of using
Bitcoin versus what you might imagine
with you know a credit card or something
like that yeah and the way I take what
you guys are doing right is I as a user
want to spend Bitcoin right so I want to
go in and use this monetary asset and I
want to purchase a good or a service so
let's say that you are Starbucks right I
want to spend Bitcoin immediately
there's a couple of challenges right so
the first is I got a half Bitcoin second
is I got a understand how to actually
transact that Bitcoin the third is that
the merchant has to be able to accept
the Bitcoin right and then the fourth is
the merchants got to figure out what the
hell do I do with this bit do I leave it
on my balance sheet do I convert it
right kind of like more like FX type
stuff you guys my understandings you've
taken a very kind of nuanced approach to
solving those problems maybe just walk
us through like a transaction what's
technically happening when I have to
fold app right and I say hey I want to
buy this cup of coffee from Starbucks
like what is the actual kind of
technical sequence that occurs so that
you solve all of those problems in that
transaction yeah I mean you hit it on
the head it's it's a confusing problem
to solve and you can't tackle you know
there are companies tackling all these
diff
pieces but the way the folds done it is
so you send fold a payment whether
that's through credit card or through
your your Bitcoin wallet
mhm and we take the payment and convert
that into prepaid credit at these
merchants and so you send us ten dollars
and you want to spend at Amazon we'll
pull ten dollars of credit from Amazon
down to you and so what this essentially
allows it allows you to do is you can
spend in whatever asset you want USD or
Fiat or USD Fiat or or Bitcoin and the
merchant can settle in this - in their
internal store credit and so the
merchant doesn't actually I have to
think about onboarding and I know all
these more complicated things about what
it means to take custody of Bitcoin what
it means to convert it and you know at a
certain point we got to figure out the
exact things we're trying to solve
because it can't solve everything right
now and so we've really focused on
solving the consumer side creating an
absolutely easy simple experience to
both earn it and to use it with the idea
that we start to demonstrate volume to
these merchants and we start to
demonstrate usage
and the one thing that fold can do that
is no other payment method can do right
now is that when you use fold you know
at say at a target the that fold user
going through your store you know from
the merchants perspective is the only
user that's not subjecting you to
processing fees from Visa and MasterCard
Network and has no ability for a
chargeback moment so for retailers
that's a huge benefit its chargebacks
processing is multi-billion dollar
headache for these merchants every year
and so what fold allows them to do is
essentially experience the possibility
of what this asset could do for them and
by adopting it without going full in and
actually having to build out that
infrastructure so we're eight we're
essentially trying to build this case by
proving out the consumer side consumer
demand and then be able to take that to
our merchant partners and start to say
okay maybe this is time for the next
stage of adoption and is your thought
process suing in that Starbucks is
essentially not taking any clinical
Bitcoin risk right they're not having to
change out their POS
system they're not having to worry about
price volatility they don't have to have
a strategy for kind of managing the
Bitcoin hedging it transacting it and
exchanging it back to dollars etc but is
the thought process like that's the
endgame where hey let's let the
consumers spend Bitcoin and then the
retailer's don't accept it because a lot
of people who would say like oh that's
not really using Bitcoin as money right
like that's just like you know any other
thing why don't we just use seashells
and then the retailers ends up with
dollars or do you look at it as no this
is the first step let's get one side of
the transaction comfortable familiar
excited about using this etc and let's
solve the problem for the other side and
then eventually we can get the retailers
to accept the actual Bitcoin itself and
like it's kind of like a gradual thing
to the transaction or is this the end
game where only one side uses it you
know this is this is all an evolution
this is what fold is creating a product
that is able to grow with the way
Bitcoin is growing in its usage and we
are on the ground because we allow you
to accumulate it spend it we actually
get to see these behaviors change about
50% of people are spending their Bitcoin
rewards 50% are saving it right now so
when we think about you know where we go
on the merchant side we're gonna go what
makes the most sense for the merchants
and build for them and so right now
settling in Fiat is the only way that
we're going to start to make this case
to those merchants and start to have
them involved in this asset now where it
goes in the future we already have
merchants that have approached us and
there are merchants currently today that
are using it and taking on Bitcoin now
that's a very small minority of them but
when we start to look at where protocol
development is an application
development is there are some use cases
where Bitcoin can be used as an
underlying asset and it's in a retail
transaction that is seamlessly in and
out of Fiat at different points and that
should support what the merchants goals
are what they want to do and so we are
very close to a world where you can walk
into a target
so use something like fold with your
credit card the transaction has actually
turned into a REIT a lightning a Bitcoin
payment the merchant gets to then settle
in the currency of their choice the coin
or whatever it is but it's giving
efficiencies to both sides so what
happens is because the merchants no
longer has processing fees and charge
back risk they're able to push all of
those rewards directly back to users to
incentivize them so the idea is aligning
incentives here and in how we can start
to rework this in the only way that
we're gonna do this is by having
real-world products that people are
using right now in checkout lines around
the country and we get to see how
behavior shifts and how it's changed and
how we can tweak these incentives on
both sides to just kind of find the
correct balance for sure and I guess for
you guys part of the benefit here is
it's not just Bitcoin only right it you
can use Bitcoin but you can also use
your regular credit card debit card etc
through the application and so it's a
little bit more consumer-friendly right
it's not this big like oh I have to
learn Bitcoin to use this fold can serve
just traditional fiat payments and so
the hope then is you kind of siphon some
of those people off into Bitcoin over
time yeah it's it's you know about
creating lowering the barrier to entry
for both consumers and merchants to
start and getting exposure to Bitcoin
and especially those that have been on
have been on the sidelines of it so
those you know we figure there's about
88 million people just in the u.s. right
now who want to have Bitcoin who want to
want to have exposure to it but it's a
fraction of that are people who actually
have it because they're the ones going
through exchanges buying it but there
are people right now who wanted it's
just the ways that we're distributing it
right now are turning some of them off
are just blocking some of them from
engaging with it and so it's it's it's
our idea to increase the amount of ways
that someone can gain exposure to it
without changing any of their daily
behaviors you know the idea of gift
cards 93% of all Americans will use a
gift card in the in a given year eighty
eighty nine percent of Americans are in
a rewards program so what we're doing is
taking existing behaviors existing
industries that people are familiar
with comfortable with and and
essentially co-opting that and in and
and viewing it was kind of bitcoin and
so you know the idea is that you are
getting adoption from people who start
to say okay maybe I'm not there at the
point where I say bitcoin is a better
money or a better dollar but bitcoin is
for sure a better airline mile or a
better or a better reward point that's
gonna be debased by you know the company
and so it's just about creating a very
slow way for people to gain exposure to
it again without changing behaviors both
on the merchant and the consumer Sun and
to me the benefit to a retailer here is
I don't pay credit card transaction fees
so let's call that you know anywhere
between one and a half and three percent
given that your size and then I also
don't have to charge back risk and so I
don't change anything in my system I
eliminate two of my biggest headaches
when it comes to payments and my
customer can still buy the exact same
products there's probably a world where
some retailer could get really
innovative or aggressive and say hey
we're actually gonna incentivize people
to use this rather than traditional
payment methods I don't know that's do a
discount or our loyalty points you know
there's all kinds of things that they
could do but it's almost like the
retailer once they realize the value
proposition they could actually help
drive the adoption because it's better
for them this is a huge trend in retail
right now credit cards right now are
increasing their processing fees really
it's it's two to four percent is really
what a retailer could expect from any
given transaction and those are showing
no signs of slowing down so much so that
you have retailers like Walmart who are
creating their own POS systems to try to
get around this because right now the
credit card rewards are in such a
competition that credit cards are giving
more and more cash back and what's
happening is that's going more and more
on the retailer's to actually pick up
the bill and so what's happening is
these retailers are now have a headache
and are actively seeking alternatives
Walmart just developed
one that goes through a CH and that's
how you pay at Walmart so people we know
that this is a problem that retailers
are facing and that they are actively
looking for alternatives and the way
that we think about this is that you
know it's either the Visa or MasterCard
giving you your rewards back or it's
actually Walmart directly giving you
your your rewards back and depending on
who's controlling the payment that's who
controls the reward and so at this point
Walmart is deeply incentivized both to
eliminate chargebacks which is a huge
multi-billion dollar issue for them but
when you're a low margin business
processing fees quickly eat up and so
you start to think about okay if we can
start instead of maybe paying two to
three percent to processing companies
and maybe we just give that exact two to
three percent as rewards back to our own
customers suddenly we have our deepened
our relationship with our own existing
customers we are not beholden to rising
processing fees and we've eliminated
chargebacks
and so again it's all about not beating
people over the head about what's great
a Bitcoin and all it's it's purely about
numbers and incentives that were that
attacked that we're taking for sure when
you guys started the company you
actually went through a venture studio
rather than you know raised kind of
angel funding exception in the beginning
maybe we talked a little bit about that
venture studio kind of how that model
works and why you guys chose to pursue
that yeah so Fuld came out of thesis
which is a venture production studio the
idea is that it it builds at the
application layer and protocol there on
top of bitcoins specifically but works
on some other protocols as well and the
idea is there's a lot of knowledge that
can be shared across projects especially
at such an early stage of the industry
where the idea of being able to harvest
as much current learnings share UX ideas
and thoughts across a broad base of use
cases allows you to Excel much faster
and so the idea is that thesis was
created to launch these use cases to
test these ideas can we change the way
people
accumulate Bitcoin let's not think about
the exchange can we create and co-op the
idea of rewards and payments and create
that as a whole new channel that
benefits consumers and merchants ok
let's go test that and so we launch
product into the market we get immediate
feedback and we see where that idea is
going is their immediate traction
because the idea is not we're not
building for the next you know a product
that will work in 20 years 10 years
we're building for products that are
businesses today and so the benefit of a
venture model like this is that we
actually get the freedom to test this in
a market that right now is super nascent
and that we get to kind of battle
battle-hardened before you know we go
all in and go all in for venture that
you know may not lead to a spot that we
want to and we're here to dedicate our
lives to this so we want to make sure
the projects were working on are our
solid have promise and actually have
somewhere to deliver value today would
it be fair to say the venture model or
venture studio model has less pressure
in the beginning so it's more of a kind
of experimentation and testing than if
you went out raised capital and like we
have to make this work the only way a
venture model works is if you actually
have people committed who have either
been entrepreneurs previously and have a
have a direct use case they want to test
or or they have brought products the
products to market or it works when you
actually have an idea that you know
already has traction and that you can
that you can just kind of add a little
bit more fuel on the fire and see where
you can go for next year and so it is
one of the things that has that you know
that doesn't work in all context like
it's not right for everybody because you
know the most important thing is to have
skin in the game and so the way that we
built the thesis model is that every
lead of a vertical so myself I was
running fold has skin the game like that
is your project if that project is not
there then you know will so we'll you
know maybe maybe there's another thing
that you can go do but the idea is that
you're that you're very deeply committed
as if you are raising funding for this
and essentially instead of getting a
larger angel or seed it's some of it's
much smaller amounts so that you can
have a place and kind of a laboratory to
test this and you do it at much smaller
timeframes we're talking under six
months and then from there once that's
validated then you can spin out go look
at seed and that's that's what fold the
Sun we just announced our seed funding
with with some incredible partners in
the space back in October
tell us a little bit more about that
right so you guys had used the venture
studio model kind of tested a bunch
figured out hey there's some traction
here we think that this got some legs to
it what was kind of the decision-making
to spin out like were there certain
milestones you were looking for or was
it more of just hey you know we're after
he's outside capital and like really go
put a full effort behind this and so
that was the driver yeah I mean it's
first of all proving at a base level you
know is there a path to a sustainable
business here are we gonna bring on
partners where we know that we have a
very good idea of how to make this into
a business today and change an execute
on our larger vision for tomorrow and
the years after and so for us it was
really important to make sure we came in
with proof points that just were able to
be blatant plain blatantly obvious for
any of these partners to bring on okay
you say that you can change behaviors
and create a new way for people to earn
Bitcoin okay let us know what the
numbers are how many people are doing
this how many have done that how much
are they earning what are they doing
what are they spending it on okay you
you say that layer two lightning is
going to be the future of Bitcoin retail
payments prove us that well we launched
lightning Pizza to be like okay we're
gonna prove that we're gonna launch a
real world service on top of lightning
and show that not only that can
lightning handle transactions that
aren't you know a couple Satoshi's but
$25 $50 and launch that on a national ID
service that anyone can use we launched
Lightning Pizza explain what that is so
lightning Pizza was a a layer over
Domino's Pizza that were allowed
lightning payments so essentially
Domino's built on lightning so anybody
could use the Lightning Network to have
Domino's Pizza delivered to them order
it in store and essentially it gave you
all the ability to
interact with a real-world service
nationwide see hey are these users just
in a pocket of New York or San Francisco
well we launched it and found that
nearly every state in the country had
activity in ordering Domino's Pizza or
the Lightning Network I just love the
name lightening pizza cuz it was
Lightning Network but also lightning
fast in terms of getting the pizza to
your door it worked in all the ways I
mean right now you know lightening pizza
for us was like an experiment a project
to figure out not only internally for us
is lightning at a mature enough level to
actually launch a real world service but
it was also about resurrecting the meme
of Bitcoin in pizza again and and to see
ok we're at a different point in Bitcoin
development and protocol development to
is finally here let's see if the if the
pizza use case can actually work now and
so we launched that we had thousands of
orders in the first days after this we
didn't even know how many people had
lightning wallets so you know shadow
it's blue wallet about 75 80 percent of
all orders came from blue wallet
custodial solution but it also proved
you know lowering the barrier to entry
into these wallets was an important
thing now long term is that where we
want to be we'll figure that out but the
idea was that right now lightning can
provide a base fun payment layer for
real world services and it can work
without breaking yeah and as you guys
built this one it was just cool to see
the community kind of rally around it
right I think was just kind of a cool
thing did a lot of had to do with the
pizza and Bitcoin memes but also it
worked right and and so you could
actually go on and use it talk to me
more about the Lightning Network itself
though right like there's a lot of
different things that you could overlay
on you know the Domino's api's and and
their website and say hey you know use X
Y Z different payment method like why
the Lightning Network and kind of give
me an understanding of like how you guys
see the state of where we are yeah it
was it was interesting I just went to
the light first lighting conference in
Berlin about a month ago and it was one
of those great moments for a kind of
State of the Union state of affairs
where we where we are in the space and I
have to say I've been blown away by the
speed of development where we've come in
the last year alone with where we are at
lightning and so number one there's a
validated large developer community
focused on this so that's you know when
we talk about building new protocols one
of the most important metrics is the
developer community and activity people
you know dedicating their their work
towards it
and it was plainly obvious how many
people are there building on various use
cases for what lightning can be
messaging on top of lightning payments
instant settlement for trading
decentralized exchanges all of these the
various things and so for us we've
chosen to explore lightning from our our
perspective of retail and adoption and
so the best part about the Berlin
conference was that was both a
celebration of all these different use
cases and how far we've come but also a
sober look of just what challenges are
there and by no means is this production
ready Domino's is ready to take this on
as their primary payment system we don't
expect that to be that for a little bit
so for us the benefits that we see going
forward with lightning are essentially
three things it's instantaneous
settlement which has implications both
for retailers and businesses to be out
the idea that you can settle and have
your money on your books that you can
spend on new inventory new marketing and
have that capital just ready to deploy
which right now you're waiting a couple
weeks to do which changes how you do
business
it has implications on the trading and
exchange side of instant final
settlement there's great talks Jack
Mallis just has done a great one about
really how revolutionary instantaneous
settlement of bitcoin actually is and so
there's the instant settlement there's
also bringing Bitcoin to low fees so you
know down to a couple Satoshi's there
which opens up a bunch more use cases
micro payments streaming payments the
thing is that lightning is not just
about replacing an incumbent payment
system it's about fundamentally changing
the fundamentals of what a payment
system can be that are far beyond the
capabilities of what we currently have
today already it's demonstrated use
cases that are just not possible from
you know an existing credit card
transaction or any other payment system
we had and so we really are looking at
lightening for those competitive
advantages and how we can leverage those
to take advantage of existing problems
like we just mentioned the process of
rising processing fees chargebacks how
do we take the things that lightning can
bring and no other payment system can do
and how do we start to introduce those
to the people that need it most
mm-hmm in the Lightning Network itself I
think one of the big kind of knocks on
it right now from the the not even
detractors as much just the skeptics
maybe is oh you can't really put a bunch
of Bitcoin through the system it doesn't
work it's not as fast as promised all
this kind of stuff like the one I focus
on the most I think is the probably most
realistic detraction is you can't put a
lot of throughput today right so we were
talking a little bit before we started
recording but maybe just describe like
why that is today and explain that kind
of how that's been a self-imposed thing
more from like a safety of the network
versus technically it's not possible
yeah you know this is absolutely a hard
cap that's been imposed by on by the
protocol development and for good reason
you know this is a fledgling Network and
it relies on robust participants in
there that can route payments you know
hop to to pump to me to someone else a
pumpkin can figure out a settlement that
requires a network that has enough
critical mass to be able to to enable
seamless payments that you can count on
ninety-nine percent of the time now when
you have an early network you just don't
have the network participation yet now
lightning has been growing and it's very
quickly gonna be on track to get there
but in these early days it's it's it's
not and so the idea is self-imposed a
[Music]
ceiling on how much a given transaction
can be right now believe it
around $400 with where we are with
Bitcoin and lightning so provide some
problems when people want to buy airline
tickets through fold but it's for good
reason it's number one keeping real
expectations real not over promising
which is a hallmark of other crypto
projects in this space and it's just
about being a way that we can both take
users on now introduce them to lightning
without putting them at risk and so all
of the issues with channel capacity
transaction size and even just the
tooling to support you know a lightning
node things like this and manage that
those are all active have active
solutions that are and then are incoming
there's amp which is gonna allow you to
break payments into much smaller
payments and route that to route that as
your payment so there's and there's new
tooling out there that just makes
spinning up a node managing it much
easier and simple so you're not losing
and having not losing any money and so
the idea is right now there's really
been no major case of any major loss of
funds which to me is incredibly
surprising given how much activity and
commerce is actually going on on the on
the Lightning Network right now and so a
lot of these are self-imposed and they
are because we know the solutions we
know generally when they'll come and
when they will we'll start to see that
those those self-imposed limits start to
relax because what the Lightning Network
is 18 maybe 24 months old in terms of
yeah I mean that you know when does when
does it start from a paper or from you
know the the first kind of release you
know I'd say a good benchmark is you
know 18 to 24 months I think that's I
think that's right when people actually
started to really build on this as a
production environment and so given
where we are today like there's been
pretty good progress right there's you
know thousands of nodes and kind of
people have really built a number of
wallets there's been an you know tens of
thousands of people who have adopted it
started using it and there's been
applications built like lightning pizza
and so again is it visa today no of
course not right but in two years or
less
it's pretty incredible the progress
especially given that it is done by kind
of a loosely coordinated group of
individuals on the internet that have
built this global product that's going
after you know some of the largest
settlement networks in the world yeah
it's it's it has been incredible to be a
part of and and to see and so you know
we have not only seen massive explosive
growth in it but we've also seen there
was a moment where a couple headlines
saying oh the you know the amount of
active nodes has gone down for a while
or the amount of you know fees has gone
down so is that is the network healthy
and actually it was a sign of maturity
for this network that people are getting
smarter about how to manage funds how to
have more efficient infrastructure so
that it can start to move to the next
level and so we're only gonna see more
and more use cases developed on top of
it there's some incredible stuff of USD
to lightning invoices which which
essentially opens up the possibility
that anybody currently with a credit
card or bank account could be spending
at retailers at an exchange with their
USD but it is actually being settled as
a Bitcoin payment so that on both sides
it's instantly settled on the side
protecting the actual receiver but on
the it doesn't require any behavioral
change from the actual initiator of the
payment and this would be US dollars
into the system converted to Bitcoin
across the Lightning Network converted
back to u.s. dollars exactly yeah so it
could be converted back to US dollars it
could be settled and kept in a lightning
Channel
the idea is that you're really
leveraging some of the again
uncompetitive advantages that lightning
and Bitcoin just present that the
incumbent world does not offer there's
nothing there's nothing like it and the
only way is to you know actually shoot
actual gold to someone add the speed of
light and then have it settled as you
know and that way there's just really no
support in any of this infrastructure
yet and so the things that I'm most
interested are really exposing and going
right after these competitive advantages
that just are not offered that provide
huge savings efficiencies and other
benefits
for both consumers and merchants traders
all you know speculators and the cool
thing is is that the Lightning community
is developing on all of these use cases
right now and so lightning is going to
make trading better lightning will make
pain better lightning will make hot
Earling better like there are ton of
things that just is all in service of
essentially adding more value to the
base chain and this is again like and we
talked about in a you know in you know a
decade is lightning gonna be it we're
betting it will you know we know it will
happen in some layer to solutions so it
there there could be a world where
another protocol is developed but right
now there's no reason to believe that
lightning won't be that solution right
now the idea of going from US dollars
across Lightning Network and back into
dollars it almost makes the dollar
transactions non sensible US dollar
transactions right which is a pretty
interesting thing to think about where
things like lighting network or the
Bitcoin network can change the way that
even Fiat holders interact with money
and the financial system it it provides
an instantaneous bridge for the the
currencies that people currently hold
whatever that may be any type of fiat US
dollars euros and creates a way for an
intent essentially an atomic swap into
any other currency around the world and
so it's not just US dollars but it is
any currency it is any asset that
lightning can facilitate instantaneous
settlements between different actors
around the globe transacting in
different currencies with zero
conversion fees on the on both sides
mm-hmm and so obviously the visa is the
master cards in lexie banking system
like that's a pretty big threat to what
they're doing
fold obviously could be a large threat
to some of the the payment incumbents as
well anything that you've seen there in
terms of how kind of the markets
responded what you guys had built so far
so I can tell you that these incumbents
are paying attention we are actively in
communication with a couple of those
those networks that you just mentioned
and we know that they are not only
paying attention but they're running
their own experiments and so for us we
we you know we see what what the
technology we're developing is could be
you know something that threatens of
their business model but we're also
seeing them start to build now I don't
think they're gonna be able to build as
fast or as as you know intelligently as
people who have skin in the game who are
you know with their ears to the ground
and really leveraging and having no
essentially incumbent business model to
protect so I do know that they're
thinking about this and I will say I
think in 2020 we're gonna hear about
some partnerships that are going to
involved in cutting involve incumbents
and start to directly introduce them
indirectly to these these you know a
lightning Network and other other other
developments for sure and you know look
it's certain
I think reporters are getting smarter
about asking these people these
questions yesterday news broke that the
PayPal CEO he owns Bitcoin right I mean
the only owns Bitcoin and some of that
is probably hey I want to see what this
is all about and learning and
experimenting some of that's I'm a
believer right and so it's interesting
to see that another aspect that I find
really interesting about Fuld that maybe
the incumbents have a different approach
is around privacy right and so the
incumbents have historically been very
susceptible to data breaches
cybersecurity attacks etc you guys are
taking a different model as to how to
protect consumers maybe describe a
little bit about what the the incumbents
challenges are and then how you guys are
solving that yeah I mean historically
you know Fuld has been working in the
checkout lines of these major retailers
for for for a while now so we understand
that we're also a a company that comes
from the Bitcoin world and so there are
certain values from bitcoiners and those
that are wanting to use a product like
fold that they want to see in the
product and the interesting thing is
those values prevent some present some
incredible opportunities for consumers
worldwide so you think about when you go
swipe your credit card
at a merchant your your location your
name your transaction details your
payment details are all then given to
this store your bank the store's bank
the payment processor any rewards
program that you're using and maybe you
know you're using a financial planning
app like a mint or something and so that
one transaction is then being
distributed all of that data across to
all of these different actors who have
various varying levels of security and
commitment to actually protecting your
data and they're almost all of them are
licensed to resell that data to you know
who knows who and so the idea is that
it's we're living in a world where our
data is just freely given in a in a
world where 50% of retailers are
compromised every single year hundreds
of millions of Americans data is is
compromised in these acts and so this
leads to huge issues with fraud and has
real impacts on credit scores that can
be that can have real impacts when
you're not taking you know a more
private secure approach to these types
of transactions and so what fold is done
is not just slap you know use Bitcoin in
payments and rewards but it's taking the
he thoughts and the values of Bitcoin
and also providing that to payments and
rewards in the way that we're doing that
is essentially ensuring that when you
use fold at a retailer you are not
leaking any of that data to them you are
the retailer is only seeing a payment
from from full and your credit card is
only sees that you're paying fold and so
it makes pseudo anonymous so you're not
tied to the things that you purchase so
advertisers can be overly targeting and
you're not for the most part you're not
leaking your private and transaction
details that can be susceptible to
attackers and advertisers like do you
think that that will eventually force
the traditional payment systems to be
more worried about privacy and they'll
move to these models or do you feel like
they just they have to stick with the
bottle they have because of the
kind of innovators dilemma yeah I think
it's that way well if there's any trend
that you can see over the last couple
decades is that the more data that you
can suck up from your consumers the the
the bit larger company you're going to
be more successful and that's just what
we've seen in the business models the
number one purchaser of this purchasing
data at point of sale is Google the
reason why they're doing is trying to
create that full picture of when what
you're searching to what you're buying
and you know ultimately create better
ads for you a more targeted ads and so
we know that the trend has been
overwhelmingly to get as much data from
consumers as possible
but what that is also done it hasn't
seen at the same time secure
infrastructure that's being built to
make sure that data is protected and
stored correctly and what happens is is
that the pendulum has just swung far too
much to one side so much so that these
retailers now are so susceptible to
these hacks that there's overwhelming
evidence that when consumers data is
compromised in a given store is named
and that compromised the kind of culprit
of where that data was compromised users
don't go back to that store upwards of
six months they it actually changes
their spending behavior which is a huge
hit to a lot of these companies and
we're only seeing this types of these
types of compromises accelerate and so I
think very much so that this is on their
radar about number one we need to be
better at what we do with data number
two companies like Apple are coming out
about protection and privacy making
these overtures of saying hey we're
gonna win more business ultimately when
we put the customer first and so I think
the narrative is starting to change now
how fast that that does depends on how
vast companies like fold and others in
the space that are doing things like
this grow when you look out 10 20 years
what's your kind of vision for where the
Lightning Network goes what does it
become
I think the Lightning network what we're
already seeing an interesting thing is
it's it's the the use cases are
diversifying there's messaging being
built on unstoppable messaging being
built on unstoppable money
we're seeing people release stable coins
and interoperability on the Lightning
Network and essentially it is this
network that allows instantaneous
settlement across parties interacting on
this network in a way that has
implications for why the wide amount of
use cases that if will affect people you
know in many ways in their lives so what
I'm looking at it from is that this is a
way as Bitcoin grows in an asset as a
Bitcoin is more widely distributed more
holders are there as the idea of how to
use Bitcoin starts to settle and it
becomes more of an asset that people are
holding but not only that are being more
and more incentivized to use in their
daily life that lightning Network will
become the way that that is used I think
that the majority of people being on
boarded into Bitcoin in the next five
years are probably going to be on board
it through layer 2 as opposed to going
on chain and so I think number one the
most obvious thing is that it's gonna
change how people experience Bitcoin for
the first time it is going to be the
layer that people are on board it
directly into and it's going to be the
layer in which provides a user
experience that is at the level if not
beyond what they expect from an existing
incumbent options and so I I think it
will soon be at a point where people
mainstream consumers could be
interacting with the Lightning Network
and not even know it and this could be
in the context of again trading retail
payments anything yeah it's super
interesting to think through kind of
where the where we're going right
understanding what the challenges are
today same question but for fault like
where do you see at 10 20 years from now
so with fold we we're and we want to
introduce you know Bitcoin to mainstream
people we want to make Bitcoin
accessible to regular people who aren't
down the rabbit hole yet yes and then be
the vehicle to drive them down that
rabbit hole and so for us you know we we
are committed to the growth of this
asset class in general we are supporting
and and here to support the values that
the base protocol has has
is already presenting to the world and
accelerate that through mass adoption
and so fourfold we not only hope to
change how people are paying and being
rewarded but we also hope to change how
those how we think of those systems
overall about focus on how do we have a
payment processor that's not built on
fees how do we have a reward system
that's not built on data harvesting how
do we take not just Bitcoin and apply
that to payments and roars but the ethos
the values of it and so what I would
hope for fold is that we are giving the
same amount of value that people may see
today from using and transacting in the
ways that they do but we're keeping them
safer while doing it we're putting the
consumer first and we are enriching them
rewarding them more than they ever have
in the past and so for us it's not just
about bringing and putting Bitcoin in
people's pockets but bringing the values
that we've learned from this asset that
this community has developed and rallied
around and put that at the very core of
of these behaviors and institutions that
historically haven't put that first yeah
it's taking a long term view and you
said it earlier it's putting the
customer first right and it's
understanding that if we do right by the
people who use our products then over a
long period of time they'll remain loyal
we'll build a sustainable business
around it will align in a win-win
situation and if you do that for long
enough everyone else kind of the flash
in the pans come and go right and you're
kind of the last person standing but
you're also the largest player and it's
pretty tried-and-true method but it
takes a lot of discipline yeah I mean
it's you know I've been an entrepreneur
building you know products for a while
and what what I found is that it is it
is a whole new game when you're building
not just you know building a business
that's hard enough for anybody but when
you're building a business in a space
like this that is also growing that is
also nascent that the there's multiple
levels now that you have to that you're
there's extra levels that you're now
having to think about and pay attention
to macro events around the world that
could directly affect how your product
works in a day to day retail transaction
for somebody and so from
it's really the only way to create a
sustainable Bitcoin business is to look
long-term but right now is to deliver
the right incentives and you know
economics today and so it's a challenge
to both have this long term vision of
where you want to be and all the things
you want to change while building a
business that delivers value today for
sure before we wrap up I always ask a
rapid-fire set of questions what do you
think is the most important company in
Bitcoin or crypto other than fold I
would say right now cash app is what it
has done an incredible job at
introducing new people to the idea of
Bitcoin in a Trojan horse capacity that
is you know taking the idea of you know
the the old venmo send and receive and
then having Bitcoin front and center
there and not only that having a
commitment to educating people about the
asset as well do you think that cash app
goes outside of just send receive buy
and hold are there other things that
they could do oh absolutely I think if
you're if you're jack what do you uh
what do you do if you're jack you take
it slow like he has been it's pretty
incredible it is I mean and I say take
it slow and actually you look at that
you look at any other companies in fact
doing this very quickly but I would say
you you continue to take it slow you are
the the main benefit that you can bring
to the space is provide a simple
accessible on-ramp for those to get
involved in the space and then from
there you'll see you'll introduce them
to a whole world of people like fold
developing new use cases and value for
that but right now the most important
thing is to create a an an easy and safe
way to onboard people into into this
asset change the way that people have
been historically on boarded into it
yeah it's um there's a saying in the
military that is a slow is smooth smooth
is fast
right and I think that's like the
perfect
kind of quote for what squares done
absolutely is they've just been very
deliberate about every action they've
made good decisions they haven't chased
things my favorite is when he gets asked
you know are you gonna credit crypto he
always responds with hell no yeah right
not know but he'll know what uh what's
the one regulation that you would change
or improve if you could oh man this is
easy one for me the the current tax
implications of spending Bitcoin the the
idea that people are exposed to capital
gains and the reporting is onerous it is
it is single-handedly hampering a
massive use case of what Bitcoin could
be and I do believe if that was changed
the narrative about what Bitcoin could
do and how much could grow would would
would drastically change now I would say
that there are technological solutions
that are coming on the horizon that are
going to whether the regulation comes or
not will will help push that forward but
that alone would would would be an
incredible help for the space for sure
what's the most controversial thought
you have in all of Bitcoin like I
believe it and everyone else is gonna
disagree with you that hyper bitcoin is
a ssin is is a wonderful idea but I do
believe it will always the one of the
benefits of real benefit of Bitcoin is
providing a counterbalance to the
existing financial system that we have
and that instead of entirely replacing
it will live alongside and provide a
level of balanced control counterweight
that will ultimately allow the benefits
that could can be brought from both
sides and allow them to co-exist do they
coexist in silos forever or is there
kind of like a merging into a new system
that that takes the benefits of both I
think there's there's there's emerging
but what it does is provides fundamental
controls on on on you know especially
the world that we live in now and you
know mmt and quantitative easing and
money printing it provides an a a check
on that almost like a balance of power
that will will make sure that the
pendulum doesn't swing as far as we've
seen it and gets
into these kind of constant crisis mode
that we're currently living in yeah
what's the most important book you've
ever read most important book I've ever
read oh man let's see I mean my favorite
I think one of the most recent books
that I have read was mutual aid what's
that it's a it's a book by this guy
named Murray Bookchin and it's it's it's
suggesting that the the way that people
evolve and develop and societies develop
is not through this idea of kind of
ruthless competition you know me over
you but it's actually when incentives
aligned to have cooperation over wide
groups of people that is not about you
know the you know winner-takes-all that
the real real progress happens when
incentives and culture is able to align
in a way that is about mutually
benefiting each other and in a society
and it's really rare and hard to get
that and we've only seen it happen a
couple times but what I love about that
is it shows so much about where we are
in this space what essentially Bitcoin
has done has been an incredible way to
align incentives over a broad diverse
group of people in a way that I think is
ultimately gonna be enriching for
everyone yeah it's pretty interesting
what's the worst book you've ever read
what's a book you read the users like
that sucked you know I you know I read I
don't know this did the book didn't suck
but I think just to be a provide kind of
a contrarian opinion like sapience I
think not impressed I it's I mean for
how much play at God I think but you
know it was fun I think I took a lot of
things from it but it's just one of
those when you look at the hype and
you're there it's it's very easy to be
like I think we went a little overboard
on this it's a safe answer when people
say like you know what book have you
read recently by saying that it brings a
lot of like oh you oh you must be
intellectual oh you know yes
aliens speaking of sapiens believer
non-believer you know this is one of my
favorite questions that you ask
partly because I actually spent a couple
weeks at the SETI Institute oh man let's
go all right spill the beans so I don't
know if you know but so Jodie Foster who
was in contact right I spent about
couple weeks with the actual Jodie
Foster the real-life Jodie Foster who
Carl Sagan wrote the book about Wow up
at the Hat Creek Observatory in Northern
California and it's set tees in the
middle of nowhere you drive out there
takes several hours to get there
cell service cuts out suddenly radio
it's only some apocalyptic preacher and
then that starts to cut out and then
it's radio silence and that's why
they've chosen this area and so you go
there and just a group of scientists
come up there they started in the 70s
and now has you know was funded by one
of the Microsoft guys and they have been
on the forefront of looking for radio
pulses around the around the universe in
SETI search for extraterrestrial
intelligent exactly so it is really okay
so this is based out in California but
there's there are installations
everywhere and it's a it's actually a a
place that has historically been funded
publicly funded but there was an a time
when oh you know I think was a
Republican senator came out but look at
all these Democrats in California
funding looking looking for aliens and
spending all your tax money so it kind
of dampened the system for a while
that's a pretty good son of the PPO
genius it's the easiest thing you could
have done and so that actually generated
a lot of private interest in us see this
is when you've got a lot of the
Microsoft guys in there and it's kind of
created a resurgence in in this search
and so I went up there we started to
increase the radio band widths of which
you could search from because you really
you're looking through this what's
called the the trough this specific
radio bandwidth that you can listen most
clearly as as widely as possible and we
were working on I got to just see these
guys working and just hanging out you
know
out for drinks and just got to just be
embedded with them and so I was what you
do because I was writing a story on them
I was up there and had been you know I
was a journalist and far in my in my
past and so I went up there and you know
they have this thing in the back of
closet they're this big
refrigerators - super dusty on top you
open it it's full of champagne
interesting and that champagne is safe
is being saved for that day Wow
there's this like interesting you talk
about subculture like Bitcoin has an
interesting subculture SETI also has an
interesting subculture yeah well we're
like the the biggest surprises so you're
going up there right you get embedded
with people who are literally searching
for extraterrestrial intelligence so you
already kind of probably have some
preconceived notions etc what was the
biggest surprise I mean I went up there
thinking I would you know see this dark
room with all of these like beeping
lights and just like you know spatial
maps happening and like a lot of energy
and it's really just a bunch of a bunch
of people sitting in like super drab
office nothing sexy about it for hours
on end just working to make the most
minut of improvements and there there's
a it's a similar thing it's a it's a
major project it's one of the only
scientific fields that you can dedicate
yourself to that has seen no measure of
progress yet they still have dedicated
their lives to it there was a gentleman
who came on the podcast and he said
every human has two questions at some
point in their life one is what happens
after death and two is are we here alone
you know right and the are we here alone
is actually the one that hasn't become
religious right that what happens after
death is much more of a religious
question but the are we here alone is
much more scientific and the part that
amazes me is you bring together so many
intelligent people and they think and
believe so many different things like
they literally argue and they will tell
you you know we've never been in contact
there's no radio
waves there's no anything and that same
person will turn around but let me show
you this you know piece of material that
we can't explain right and so it's
interesting but to me the part that I
always go back to is it would be one of
the greatest scientific breakthroughs of
our life is the person or the group that
contacts or identifies extra structure
your life and mathematically there's a
very high probability that it's out
there do you think with the time you
spent there this is more of a we might
not have the tools to actually be able
to probe far enough or is this a there's
so much like herd mentality everyone's
looking at it the same way and we just
may be wrong in our approach so far yeah
I think we are one of the things I
learned is how actually limited we are
it's really cool to see when you you
know again there's so many parallels to
Bitcoin community its space like the
promise of what it could be could be
massive but when you actually start
talking to the builders and the people
there they're super very realistic about
the challenges in that they have to
overcome and the limitations that they
have in rational very rational and you
have to be that way but else you have to
have that split mind like you just
talked about of also keeping an eye on
the larger vision and so I kind of a map
the thing where right now our tools seem
like they are so very limited to do this
where we would have already been we
would have been approached farther if
there was an advanced civilization and
so the best bet that we can be thinking
about now is finding a civilization that
is it is less advanced than us and even
at a kind of microbial level if anything
and so it's it's one of those things
where they're both preparing for
linguistically how to speak to
extraterrestrials when they get here but
also knowing that maybe they should be
tooling their tools for looking for
lower stage civilizations as well that's
incredible to hear that not only is SETI
looking for extraterrestrials but
they're also preparing what happens if
they come here oh yeah this is so follow
Seth Shostak he's also he's one of the
guys all the Hollywood films go to but
his I think at one point
his title was like head of
extraterrestrial communications or
linguistics there's a badass natives I
am absolutely if you could aspire to any
title I think that guys might just
change my [ __ ] title to that right
now actually you speaking to the Airways
like this could that could make sense
and you know it's but it's a it's this
this group is incredibly smart they're
you know most of them are outta stanford
there's a lot over here on the East
Coast but their lives a lifestyle is
actually really great there's Arecibo in
Puerto Rico
there's Hat Creek up in Northern
California there's a couple over here
and Greensboro and you know they're just
there's some in Hawaii there they're
hopping to these incredible locales on
the hunt for aliens but living a good
life while they're at it yeah it's uh
it's the one thing that fascinates me
it's just odds are they're out there you
know you know are we gonna find them are
they gonna find us and and then knowing
they're there kind of identifying this
is fact is a big deal but then obviously
being able to interact is is the part
I'm personally most interested in and my
fascination we thought this all started
with one simple question which is uh do
you think that aliens have pets I I
would have to say yes I would absolutely
have to say yes and maybe we will
hopefully we don't become their pets in
the future and they find a new pet shop
here I would like it to maybe be the
other way around yeah but yeah I'm gonna
go for a hard YES on that it just it
feels like it's um it's the part of
aliens no one ever talks about right we
all think like the little green man
showing up but like is he rolling up
with you know pets or hurt how's it
coming alone awesome what Oh what one
question do you have for me to to finish
it out so you know we you have builders
coming up here and and you know they're
all hyping chillin their own projects
where do you feel is the most exciting
new development in the space coming from
like what what right now is it we know
that it's you know speculation all that
but like what is
new kind of take or inside that you have
that you're you're paying attention to
yeah so I'm gonna answer a little
probably not the way you want me to but
it's a non-technical thing and it's the
time elapsing that allows for the
legitimization of Bitcoin and what I
mean by that is you know eleven years
ago white paper gets published to most
of the world they would say you know
quote-unquote nerds and there you know
cryptographic experts they're people who
are kind of on the fringes of society
for the most part you know it's not like
CNN was covering the you know
cryptography mailing list right type
thing today you know this year in 2019
we've seen the president tweet about it
we've seen Congress and Senate hold
multiple hearings we've seen congressmen
who literally have said you know on this
on the congressional floor
you can't stop Bitcoin it's unstoppable
right that was amazing yeah you see you
know and and and the to to me that they
get you know probably not enough credit
or Warren Davidson and Patrick McHenry
right like I mean they're full-on pit
corners like that they see the future
they get it they're they're behind it
etc you see countries even like China
right Russia Venezuela right that are
again approaching this as not a question
of hey is this going to be a thing and
more a question of like what are we
gonna do when this thing is a thing yeah
right and so to me like that's been the
big leap over the last two years is it
went from like oh what do you like crazy
people on the internet doing like you
know oh the reddit community you know
they've got some new thing I don't know
they got Bitcoin they got dogecoin right
now there's been like a true separation
I think in the legitimacy of bitcoins
real right like the president we did
about it and there's probably still a
lot of questions and kind of like maybe
it's a thing maybe it's not with
everything else like when I talk to
institutional investors they don't talk
about anything other than Bitcoin
yeah like day and some of us they don't
know right so that it actually don't
even know the names of other things or
to ask about them and some of its just
like in their mind
bitcoin is like the most legitimate
thing that they could put in their
portfolios and so they're trying to
understand it so to me like that's been
the biggest development what I don't
know is like how much farther can it go
right like yeah there's like some big
things like you know central bank puts
it in their reserves or where our
country says it's a you know a
recognized reserve currency two
countries start like trading and
settling in Bitcoin right like like
there's some of these like big big
moments maybe a country comes out and
says hey you know we just put two
billion dollars into an energy project
to mine Bitcoin like that type of stuff
those are like I still think pretty far
away I don't think that's gonna happen
tomorrow but you know look I've been
told by multiple people around the world
who you know would be in the know
there's many countries that are mining
Bitcoin right you know and all this kind
of stuff again it's just like everyday
it's like 1% improvement right are 1%
more legitimate and then you look back
and you know were 11 years in you're
like hey man like CNBC can't get enough
of this yeah and like now they're
they're talk about price right and so
that they're not talking to us sorry
about the things that you know around
adoption or things that you guys are
working on etc but price then gets to
what are people actually doing with it
which gets to mining which then gets to
adoption which you know I'm waiting for
who's the first news station that
reports during earnings season the
Bitcoin transaction volume for the last
you know three months and compares it to
venmo PayPal Apple pay you know
everything else like to me that's where
you get a really really interesting
dynamic because now it's not just hey
Bitcoin as an asset its Bitcoin as a
payment product is reaching mainstream
yeah and so I think that's kind of like
that whole thought process or you know
conscious stream is something I'm paying
a lot of attention to because I think
it's really really important because it
elicits the capital into the system to
let everyone go build I couldn't agree
more there's been a palpable shift this
year I believe in that in that way and
yeah let's get back to building minting
new bitcoiners I mean part of what we
are here at fold is also it's not just
about getting more people
it's about establishing an electorate of
people with Bitcoin that have those
values defended in in the public sphere
and slowly and then all at once you know
absolutely where where can people go
find more about fold or find you in the
internet so folds available Android app
store you can find us at fold app comm
and you know you can always reach out to
me if you're ever having any issues I
have some feature requests you know I'm
at WL RVs give me a shout and you know
we are building for you all so don't
don't be a stranger go download the app
yeah man thanks so much to do it again
it's been good